[Music]
let's see
so i did want to play this
i'm not i'd already said i'm not playing
any of the [ __ ] january 6 [ __ ]
hearing but you did mention why is joe
rogan on the screen
isn't he an insurgent well it's funny
it's funny you mentioned that because
they're calling him that now because
are you aware of the agent provocateur
aspect of january 6th
oh boy joe
joe
buddy
buddy i like you joe
buddy careful bud
say more um
i don't exactly know what the reality is
but the
what people are insinuating is that
there was federal agents that were
involved in instigating the violence
instigating the entering into the
capital and that there's this one guy in
specific that they've got him isolated
on video they've
shown him over and over again he's faced
no legal consequences
they know this guy's name they know
exactly who he is all these other guys
are in jail all those other guys who got
into the capital i mean so many of them
are facing like these massive federal
charges and four years plus in jail
this one guy is like we have to go in
there we have to take back we have to
get inside there and people start
calling them a fed in in one one of
these videos and
you know what's funny
about the world we live in
is that infinitely more people are gonna
see this seven minute clip of joe rogan
than they're gonna watch that january 6
committee hearing that they did yeah is
that not a fact get ready for a wave of
[ __ ] joe rogan hit pieces again yep
is joe rogan responsible for the poppy
kringo or whatever yeah
that'll be the way they finally take
them down
that's how they're gonna destroy joe
rogan's career is joe rogan's
responsible for brendan
i think he like takes off runs away but
this is what it seems like it seems like
and this is something that
governments have done forever right you
take a peaceful protest what's the best
way to break up a peaceful protest you
bring in agent provocateurs to turn it
into another maybe you know have stacks
of bricks by every single [ __ ] riot
that happened but when you bring that up
your conspiracy remember that
after the george floyd stuff there just
happened to be a bunch of bricks in all
these major cities that they were just
out there brick delivery service here
get your throwing bricks like wait a
minute is there a car chase coming in
soon is that why you keep carrying these
bricks up back down the street
and my our job is to walk this pane of
glass back and forth across the street
and this guy he's supposed to stack
watermelons all day man i sure hope that
pays off later
non-peaceful a violent protest smash
windows light things on fire then you
can send in the troops and you can clean
up the mess and then you don't have any
protest anymore this was the world trade
organization in what was it in seattle
in 99 or whatever it was that's what
they did
joe
has been watching that kitty history
video a little too much yeah it's still
too much buddy it's a little too much
but
it's been documented that is what
happened i mean like literal government
agents went in wearing
antifa outfits and starts this is pre
antifa right smashing windows lighting
things on fire and they were all
eventually released conveniently well
this guy do you know about this jamie
you know see if you can find it
because it's a curious case of this one
particular individual who's like i can't
wait for that movie the curious case of
ray epps uh this particular individual
yelling see some problem
yeah sorry i haven't seen this one i
remember the umbrella man who was uh
breaking windows at the george floyd oh
[ __ ] you know what the ray apps i
[ __ ] he good point we you know we
comp we covered that and i've completely
forgotten about that because the new
cycles always go so fast remember the
umbrella guy at the autozone the george
floyd thing that nobody arrested that
was actively trying to start [ __ ]
telling him to go in the autozone
riots i think they found out that that
guy was a cop
think joe
joe
you think
and that
i think that was like a rogue human but
no i'm not sure if that's true but so
this is where it's interesting with in
this case i don't know the case at all
but is it that
somebody in government actually
initiated him doing it as an agent
provocateur to shut down the protest or
was he someone who happened to be in
government who was himself radicalized
to acting on his own because of
radicalization did the thing or is he an
agent
if he was acting honest if he was acting
on his own
then why isn't he arrested
guy i don't know who this guy is but if
he was think about this
person who thinks he's smart because
he's on joe rogan
if he was radicalized why wouldn't he be
arrested the government would
immediately go see they're infiltrating
our government he would be he would be
the the fir he would be the first person
indicted if there was a government
person that turned
remember that dea agent
that got her that got fired from his job
he never never went in the building he
was peacefully protesting
uh on january 6 and they fired him yep
tour but he's doing so independently
just because he's a [ __ ] psycho you
know some firemen start fires right but
notice that
whichever view you have you probably had
a motivated interest to see it that way
right yeah i didn't have any view on it
right that's the thing i'm looking at it
like this like what is it what is this
video yeah i'm watching this guy like
this one big beefy looking federal agent
guy telling them they got to go inside
and i think he was wearing a maga hat
and uh you know it's like a guy in his
50s then and he's like i'll tell you
what we got to do we got to get inside
there we got to go inside the capitol
and these people like inside like isn't
that illegal
again
you know why the joke you know why joe
rogan is a good barometer of
and this is i figured it out average
morons that are kind of only casually
paying attention
perfect
joe that you exactly what i was going to
say joe rogan is the i was going to say
my bobby heanen line the ham and eggers
ham and eggers what whatever whatever
joe rogan's the character in the movie
that's supposed to be you
like yes watching things
you know like joe rogan's the character
there explaining all the exposition to
you know it's like oh i'm caught up now
that's the bad guy that he's explaining
to me about okay joe joe you know what
exactly joe rogan is the nameless skyrim
character you know yes
like that's what he is and that's a
perfect and that's not even an insult
i'm not even being an insult
insulting joe because we're [ __ ]
morons too we're a big bunch of dumb
idiots too we're not smarter than
anybody joe rogan's the horse thief
going you're looking at the true king of
skyrim
thanks regular dude in form clothes
explaining that to me yeah i didn't know
who anybody was i just woke up in this
cart
and brandon shaw walks up he goes i used
to be a fighter until i got an arrow in
the brain
[Laughter]
but but that's that's exactly joe rogan
is the greatest barometer of independent
people in what they're thinking people
that don't normally follow this stuff
and then the guy who tries to run from
the materials is they're trying to
behead him and brendan shaw's like hey
man that's not masking right
what the [ __ ] this guy's taking it to
the next level but he's doing it like
multiple
times that's the the pro there's a there
is a real problem with intelligence
agencies doing that kind of [ __ ] totally
wait i'm sorry
how can you say something
yeah so controversial and yet so brave
joe are you telling us that now in 2022
the guy who used to be into conspiracy
theories hardcore is just realizing
that maybe there's a problem with
intelligence maybe they've been lying to
you
remember when almost all the people that
tried to kidnap gretchen whitmore had to
be released
every one of them
and they haven't said a retrial you saw
that if they were social they are
letting that go they're like yeah
they're letting that one go
this is fine
how cool would that be if you [ __ ]
got to got to be involved got like
like wrapped up with some fbi agents
that convinced you to kidnap the
governor and then you're found not
guilty and you're like that was the
wildest ride ever i know it boys i'm
just gonna chill out now yeah i'm just
gonna chill out i'm gonna probably join
a bowling league
you do do it and i think they do it
thinking that this is like these group
of [ __ ] psychos like we gotta
stop this from
escalating so here's the way we get him
to do something really stupid then we
can put fences up and create a green
zone and then we lock this down
meet ray epps
oh he's pulling up the story yeah
[ __ ] dad
meet ray epps the fed protected
provocateur who appears to have led the
very first um 1-6 attack january 6th
attack on the us capital so let's watch
some of this because
oh these are guys
there we go okay i want to get to the
video
we need to go into the capitol
did you hear somebody go
what that was that's why don't you show
that in the hearings did you see that we
didn't call the capitol
what that is that is
that is what a real
like conservative sounds like exactly we
need to go in there and check whoa
what
hey
we were just here to you know have our
voices heard and [ __ ] homie let's style
that back a little bit happens
that scares the [ __ ] out of me because
that's into the capitol
into the capitol tomorrow neither what i
don't even like to say because i'll be
arrested
but you're not but that's the problem
ray
you were never arrested sir you're still
wearing your badge around your neck
[ __ ] seriously man
god damn it
we need
we need to go i'll say it all right we
need to go in shut the [ __ ] up boomer to
[Music]
it's that direction
it's
that direction come on
who's coming with me
not me man
we need to go kill the president what
what
[Music]
okay i think and the best place to do is
from the hubers morris building across
the rock ferrell hewitt building because
of a clear line of sight to the
president's bedroom and
there's a lot of instances it goes on
for quite a while there's a lot of
videos of this guy which is really
fascinating because
i
rogan's tv is so much bigger than mine
my tv used to be that size oh my god my
tv was not that size what six
that's like a [ __ ] dude that's like a
[ __ ] 15 thousand dollar tv
mine was a 70 inch tv
i think these methods that they've used
forever
yours was as big as his relative to your
levels of wealth that's fair enough
fair enough
i meant to tell you by the way getting a
salt tank installed next week there you
go nice we're going to do some nice hot
hot yoga yeah
yeah soak in the salt tub yes
also i got a bunch of monkey hormones
that we're going to take
got him down with let's do it
i'm now on
let's [ __ ] go i'm all good on tests i
don't care
my dht levels are in the toilet now
let's go
what are you saying frozen
now you're gonna start raising chickens
no subverted by social media because you
have a hundred thousand different
cameras pointed at this guy from all
these when someone starts screaming
loudly people start filming it and then
you get a conglomeration they're a
collection of these rather and you can
go what is happening here like like i
don't think they've realized that people
would be so cynical that they would go
over all these various videos and find
this well then they're stupid like how
did they not think
by the way can i say
one of my favorite things is rogan
using the word cynical when he met
autistic because that's no but that's
what he meant right that people would be
so cynical no no no no no no no no it's
the people that are so autistic they
were going to find this the problem is
with you feds is that you they've been
doing this for years the issue is is now
like rogan said they're getting to the
point where no matter what they do
there's a [ __ ] camera in their face
you know what i mean like this is these
aren't the days where you could you know
oh yeah man i'm gonna just i'm gonna go
infiltrate this thing and you get away
with it now it's like they'll know
exactly where you live how long you've
served in the fbi like
it's the same thing with like it's the
same thing with like corrupt cops
getting away with [ __ ]
and it's like they got away with [ __ ]
for years and now there's body cams and
everybody's like wow are all these cops
so corrupt and you're like yeah i mean a
lot of them always were it's just now
they forget to turn their body camera
off when they playing drugs
and then they gotta then they gotta go
to court and lose their whole job over a
little whoops of daisy